bei rolex trade up haben wir schon
einige ausgefallene oder verrückte dinge
gemacht um an geld zu kommen was aber in
dieser folge passiert ist komplett krank
und nur die wenigsten wissen dass haben
damit überhaupt geld verdienen kann wir
müssen nach portugal wir müssen unser
revier markieren in bis zu 15 meter höhe
arbeiten und unsere gesundheit aufs
spiel setzen wir werden in dieser folge
einen tag lang viel in kärnten gehen und
warum die portugiesen dass das grüne
gold nennen das unheimlich gefährlich
war und wie viel wir an einem tag
verdient haben erfahrt ihr in dieser
folge von rolex
[Musik]
die pinien saison startet genau am
ersten dezember aber auch schon in den
tagen davor gilt es eine menge zu regeln
das richtige werkzeug muss gekauft und
gebaut werden und zu einem großteil
werden irgendwelche sachen irgendwie
zusammen geschweißt um so eine lange
paul zu haben um an die pinien traum zu
kommen und vor allem muss das revier
markiert werden was machen wir gerade
hat ja gerade ist die entdeckung hier
von den pinien bäume die wir morgen am
ersten tag pflücken und konnten gerade
eben ob nun doch verlassen wollen ist
welche bäume wir am ersten tag blicken
können korrigiert zum beispiel ist ein
großer baum den werden wir
wahrscheinlich pflücken der ist denkt
auf der straße das heißt ist eine für
jeden zeltplatz bäume auf grundstücken
gehören natürlich den leuten denen die
grundstücke gehören abseits davon stehen
aber überall in portugal diese linien
rum also auch am straßenrand in parks
und genau die gilt es zu klemmen genau
die muss man als sein revier markieren
option eins als erster da sein und die
einfach pflücken option 2 genau das was
rafah gemacht hat schilder anfertigen
und die an diese bäume hängen
verkaufen
sie sind nicht die einzigen und sie
waren noch nicht die ersten die auf
diese idee gekommen sind also musste ein
bisschen nachgeholfen werden
[Musik]
morgens hieß es dann hoffen dass wir die
ersten und hoffen dass wir die einzigen
sind damit wir nicht um bäume verhandeln
oder um es um die bäume streiten
um kurz vor 6 ich habe gerade brötchen
geschmiert und jetzt scheint es los zu
gehen alle sind richtig pump und heute
ist der große tag
36 wir werden uns erst um nichts kümmern
die allgemein zugänglich sind wo
theoretisch jeder der hier in der gegend
fliegt einfach so hingehen könnte weil
es öffentliche bäume sind weil die an
der straße stehen und die grasen er als
allererstes ab damit wir eben die ersten
sind und uns quasi die bäume gehören das
ist aufgabe nummer 1 und danach geht es
dann richtung bäume die wirklich auch
uns gehören also die auf grundstücken
stehen von von freunden von freunden
familien und so weiter jetzt müssen wir
hoffen dass noch niemand vor uns da ist
weil an dem ein oder anderen gestern
schon ein schild dran hängen sieht aber
scheinbar ganz gut aus hier ist schon
die erste kreuzung genau hier stellen
wir das auto darunter weil dann kann
kein anderer die pinien bäume die
eigentlich alles unter wasser
[Musik]
geht jetzt als erstes hoch ich warte
noch ein bisschen ein bisschen heller
wird weil ich wirklich das gefühl habe
das nicht richtig einschätzen zu können
auf der kamera sieht es wahrscheinlich
sogar heller aus als wirklich ist die
sonne ist noch nicht aufgegangen und
treffer zeigt mir jetzt erst mal wie es
geht erst in diesem moment habe ich
gemerkt was es wirklich heißt hinzufügen
die leiter alleine waren zirka acht
meter und von dort aus ging das klettern
erst wirklich los also im endeffekt
bewegt man sich auf bis zu 15 metern im
baum würde ich sagen und das komplett
ohne sicherung dann sagen wir jetzt hell
also es ist schon schon deutlich krasser
als ich mir vorgestellt habe aber es
sind auch schon einige pinien unten ich
werde jetzt gleich meinen ersten versuch
wagen und hier auch auf einen dieser
bäume klettern wir ein bisschen
angespannt angespannter als gedacht
hätte
mk
[Applaus]
das problem ist ich weiß auch nicht so
genau auf welche erste ich mich hier
verlassen kann und auf welche nicht
becker ich habe keine ahnung wo ich fest
packen sobald
die leute erwischt
ich krieg' ich hin
[Musik]
ich hatte wirklich große probleme zum
einen hatte ich wie so eine sperre in
meinem kopf ich hatte das gefühl ich
kann das nicht das ist zu unsicher und
irgendwie habe ich mich einfach nicht
wohl gefühlt und es dann beim ersten
baum einfach sein lassen es hat nicht
geklappt es hat nicht gepasst und ich
habe wirklich angefangen zu zweifeln ob
das das richtige für mich ist
[Musik]
ok
im prinzip ist das hier
genau das was wir wollen
katrin schinköth ihn jedes mal wenn man
so ein ding ab macht bares geld ich war
unglaublich happy das ist dann auch beim
2 besser funktioniert hat ich hoch
gekommen bin und als ich dann mal oben
war und so auf 13 14 15 metern stand war
die angst plötzlich weg
[Musik]
da wir sind so backen hoch ich bin auf
dem baum zweiter versuch hat geklappt
ich hatte immer drei kontaktpunkte beide
beine und einen arm und konnte dann mit
dem anderen arm dieb ihn herunter holen
das hat sich komplett sicher angefühlt
aber das war es natürlich nicht ich bin
happy dass es geklappt hat weil ich
dachte gerade eben beim ersten baum
wirklich so auch ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass das nichts wird aber
falls ihr euch mal gefragt habe warum
pinien so teuer sind genau das ist der
grund pinien können nicht maschinell
gepflückt werden das bedeutet man ist
darauf angewiesen dass leute wie rafa
oder ich auf den baum klettern die
pinien runterholen und die von dort aus
dann weiterverarbeitet werden niemand
von den leuten mit dem wir gearbeitet
haben war gesichert mit einem
klettergurt oder mit seilen mit
irgendwas man macht einen fehltritt und
du fällst die kompletten 15 meter runter
da führt kein weg dran vorbei also fast
egal wieviel jetzt am ende des tages
dabei rumkommt es lohnt sich die eigene
sicherheit für ein bisschen geld oder
für einen guten lohn aufs spiel zu
setzen macht überhaupt keinen sinn das
ganze jetzt mal für einen tag zu machen
hat sich noch okay an gefühlt weil ich
nicht auf das geld angewiesen waren
einfach hätte sagen können hey bis
hierhin und nicht weiter ich fühle mich
unsicher ich will es nicht machen wenn
du das aber als hauptjob oder als saison
job machst und du wirklich darauf
angewiesen bist deine deine miete zu
zahlen und du darauf angewiesen bis dann
auf 15 metern zu arbeiten dann bekommt
das schon wirklich einen faden
beigeschmack erster baum von mir ist
fast durch rafas zweiter hier unten
liegen da wird schon einige hier hat der
date an runtergeholt ich sind schon die
sind schon schön daher weist so gut
ausgesucht die hier
walter weeger nachdem die pinien auf den
boden geworfen haben haben wir die erst
alle probiert auf einen haufen zu tun
und jetzt in diese weißen säcken
verpackt 30 und 50 kilo säcke sind das
und das sind alles nur bäume die
öffentlich zugänglich sind
manni glitt wir haben schon über 150
kilo gepflückt jetzt an pinien day von
ich zusammen die saison hat jetzt bei 1
euro 20 angefangen das heißt ein kilo
pinien ping im frischen zustand der
ganze zapfen kostet dann also ein euro
20 das heißt 150 kilo mal 21 haben wir
so zwei euro
für den vormittag lücken wenn auch
gespannt was die anlagen gepflegt haben
weil ihr macht das in der gruppe ja
immer so dass sie alle an verschiedenen
standorten fliegt dann aber alle
zusammen werft und das geld aufgeteilt
wird ja genau weil jeder hat halt so
seine spots zum pflücken am ersten tag
das ist ein bisschen ein kleines fest
hier und da durch feiern wir das dass
wir einfach alle alle irgendwo pflücken
gehen und dann einfach alles
zusammenschmeißen einmal richtig schön
essen gehen und dann über die ganze
andere saison kümmert jeder sich um
seinen eigenen kram ok schön und gut wir
pflücken die pionieren wir sammeln die
pinien wir verkaufen die pinien klar das
hört sich jetzt erstmal so ganz witzig
am aber warum eigentlich was ist daran
eigentlich so viel geld wert und wo
steckt das geld genau in den zapfen und
zwar das hier ist jetzt ein voll
ausgewachsener pinienzapfen und wenn ihr
euch das anschaut dann sieht man hier so
lauter sage ich mal einen hellen und in
jeder lamelle sage ich mal sind zwei
pinienkerne drin deshalb wirklich nur
zwei bis drei prozent pinienkernen und
das macht das ganze so besonders weil
wie ihr seht steinhart wenn du so ein
ding auf dem kopf bekommt alter diesen
so schwer wenn du das auf dem kopf
bekommt müsste noch dran riechen da ich
nicht mal tragen alter und spaß naja es
krass dass hier könnt ihr euch einfach
ins auto hängt ganzes jahr lang hat den
besten duft überhaupt wir können daraus
auch ein parfüm entwickeln oder so ohne
apps schliesst diese pinienzapfen müssen
sozusagen in einem ofen gelagert werden
und dort erhitzt werden so dass sie nach
und nach aufbrechen das hier ist jetzt
natürlich ganz natürlich hat sich das
geöffnet und wenn wir dann mal hier rein
schauen dann finden wir hier diese
schwarzen hosen genau das hier und hier
drin ist der pinienkerne com nicht warum
die pinienkerne aber da ist auf jeden
fall der pinienkernen drin genau da ist
im kern jetzt erst mal hier auf dem
truck und ab in die richtung
wo wir jetzt wiegen und verkaufen gehen
wurde gerade erst mal ein bisschen
hähnchen und pommes gekauft franco
händchen
weil der erste dezember wie so ein
feiertag unter den pinien flug ms werden
alle pinien der gruppe zusammen geworfen
und am ende das gesamte geld geteilt
dann so auf dem truck zu sehen was einen
tag arbeit im endeffekt wirklich keine
auswirkungen hatten das alles voll war
mit pinien war schon sehr beeindruckend
und es war auch sehr schön dass der tag
dann irgendwann zu ende gehen weil es
ist wirklich ein knochenjob also es ist
einfach harte arbeit gefährliche arbeit
und für mich war es gut dass es dann
auch irgendwann zu ende ging
[Musik]
in dieser verkaufsstelle wird alles
gesammelt und großhandels mäßig dann
nach italien verkauft wo die pinien
weiterverarbeitet werden von hier werden
jetzt alle unsere säcke auf die wagen
gepackt da steht und dann kommen die da
in dieses riesen lager und jetzt
erfahren wir endlich wie viel geld wir
heute an dem tag eingenommen haben ich
bin super drauf was glaubt zur schätzung
der tonne würden wir eine tolle schnack
das sehr viel
750 ja sogar mehr insgesamt sind an
diesem tag
749 kilogramm pinien zusammengekommen
von uns einer gruppe aus fünf personen
[Musik]
ein kino bringt beim momentanen kurs 1
euro und 35 cent was insgesamt einem
preis von 1000 11 euro insgesamt
bedeutet das dass pro person 202 euro
und 23 zentrum gekommen sind was eine
menge geld ist für einen tag arbeite ich
keine frage das ist wirklich eine menge
geld für das risiko aber lohnt sich dass
in keiner welt ich würde es niemand
braten ich finde es ziemlich krass dass
die alle ohne sicherung unterwegs sind
und es ist so leid es mir tut und ich
wünsche es niemanden fast nur eine frage
der zeit bis irgendeiner der erste das
gewicht nicht hält bis eben scheiße
passiert ich habe auch mit hafer
gesprochen das passiert halt das ist
einfach nicht vermeidbar wenn man
ungesichert auf diesen bäumen brummt und
deswegen ich kann das nicht so richtig
befürworten es war trotzdem eine geile
erfahrung ich würde mir wünschen dass
die ganzen jungs das anfangen mit
sicherung zu machen an sicherheit eine
menge spaß gemacht und ich bin froh dass
du dir 200 euro mehr in der rolex trade
up kasse haben vergesse ich den kanal zu
abonnieren damit ihr keines der
folgenden videos verpasst besonders
nicht die helium auf lösungen die
nächste woche kommt und dann
möglicherweise auch das große finale von
rolex trade up vielen dank dass sie bis
hierhin angeschaut habt wir sehen uns am
donnerstag wieder cous cous cous
geht man raus alter
[Musik]
[Gelächter]